club at lake las vegas will benefit  following a large purchase of fireworks  tim brooks the owner and ceo of rainbow  club and emerald island casino  in henderson's water street district  purchased more than 3  thousand dollars worth of fireworks to  help support the roid club based in  henderson  he plans to hold a drawing and give the  fireworks  to the winners the 10 winners at each  drawing for a total of 40 winners  28 each property and everybody goes home  with a smile on their face and the money  in their pocket because they save money  on fireworks  the lake las vegas rowing club's mission  is to educate people and promote the  sport of roaring throughout the las  vegas valley with a focus  on youth athletes the club provides  junior level athletic training and  scholarships  for higher education to its club members